hello the Internet I'm gap I'm done I
know we've built this little Lego tower
not realistic I'm always fascinated by
how when you film something in slow
motion it kind of adds scale to it makes
everything seem a bit weightier
is that what they doing Thunderbirds and
stuff like that yeah and like
Independence Day had a lot of model
shots at school so what we're doing with
this lovely little town we've got a town
it took us ages to build have a
three-hour build you wouldn't think it
but it did got a plane I'm gonna crush
it through the back of slow MA Palace
and hopefully you get some cool shots
there's a plane right now yeah see you
later hopefully get some quite cool
shots of its exploding everywhere people
going flying buildings collapsing that
sort of you yeah the pilot is not aware
he's about to have an engine failure
yeah six feet six feet six feet that's
deadly deadly please for this guy's got
no idea those having a proof yeah just
chilling
all right let's sir see how are you on
cool want to explain what happened last
time we did this well basically plane
did you cut there's no we're good to
hold it under the wings which would be
the logical sort of balanced place to
hold it so you have to hold it back here
which is unbalanced which means that
when I threw it it just took a nosedive
it immediately crashed into the table I
don't get a practice shot either you
know there's no practice and messing it
up will cost us hours several hours of
work
it's really hard to throw that Oh
where's the plane Oh where's the wings
just forget nightmare to rebuild that
play
what happened Oh personal first of all
you broke the plane in your hand and
then nothing it vertically downwards is
completely the center gravity plane is
not made for throwing
oh you put such as the bag didn't break
it through it
the control tower didn't even get to
hide I mean that looks really cool it
looks cool but it's look like a plane
crash it just looks like some smashed
Lego that's completely gone yeah the boy
did some actually catastrophe it's cool
use a large coming towards the corners
wicked stuffs gone everywhere my
favorite part is this for your face Oh
God say yeah how that go no perhaps not
for her engine one fiber my huh oh dear
concentration yeah that looks wicked
didn't end your face
let go it's gone straight for the tower
oh why tell his booty what that sideways
Jesus in again now the back of this guy
there's an engine flying towards it
Vince the fuselage lega everywhere so
that when the plane had an extreme
amount of velocity yeah what were its
integrated and went straight through but
then done we've reconstructed it yeah in
a very likely plane crash sonar this is
quite realistic I think but a something
happened when the plane crashed didn't
it yeah those sort of jet fuel went
everywhere no just all over the gap
so notice this forklift guy looks a bit
like Walter White
yeah he really does it looks exactly
like him that's amazing
that was absolute destruction yeah they
don't know him today they never saw it
coming I feel sorry for anything yeah Oh
a slo-mo bill is a slow mop Alice it's
been packed back up it spits box look
this guy is totally charred it cups
melted it's wine glasses melted
oh well as a stupid video very silly one
hopefully you enjoyed it I loved it and
I kind of want to do something similar
on that small scale but larger smaller
but larger yeah yeah coming so make
sense be sure to subscribe to us you can
buy shirt don't loads of those follow us
on Twitter
thank you very much for watching
Oh